>>> THIS MORNING, OUR SERIES
"EYE ON EARTH" GOES TO ENGLAND
TO SEE WHAT COULD BE THE NEXT
REVOLUTION IN AIR
TRANSPORTATION.
COMMERCIAL AIRLINE TRAVEL IS A
MAJOR SOURCE OF PLANET WARMING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
UNLIKE ELECTRIC CARS, VIABLE
ELECTRIC AIRPLANES HAVE BEEN OUT
OF REACH SO FAR.
MARK PHILLIPS, THOUGH, FOUND OUT
THAT ELECTRIC-POWERED FLIGHTS
COULD TAKE OFF SOONER THAN YOU
THINK.
>> Reporter: THIS ONE LOOKS LIKE
THE RED BARON'S WORLD WAR I
TRIPLANE HAD TO GOOD A TIME AT
THE PARTY.
THIS LOOKS LIKE LUKE SKYWALKER
MIGHT USE IT ON THE SCHOOL RUN.
AND THIS ONE LOOKS LIKE A FLASH
FROM THE PAST THAT DOESN'T FLASH
VERY FAST.
WHAT THEY'RE ALL TRYING TO LOOK
LIKE IS THE FUTURE OF AVIATION
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL DESIGNED TO
FLY ON A REVOLUTIONARY NEW FUEL
FOR AIRPLANES -- ELECTRICITY.
HOW FAR ARE WE AWAY FROM HAVING
THE HOLY GRAIL OF AVIATION, AN
ELECTRIC AIRPLANE?
>> A FULL ELECTRIC AIRPLANE IS A
LITTLE WAY AWAY.
THE BIG PROBLEM WITH
FULL-ELECTRIC FLIGHTS STILL AT
THIS MOMENT IN TIME IS POWER
DENSITY.
>> Reporter: POWER DENSITY IS
AIRPLANE SPEAK FOR THE FACT THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO FLYING THERE'S
NOTHING LIKE AVIATION FUEL.
IT MAY BE POLLUTING, BUT POUND
FOR POUND IT PACKS 14 TIMES THE
PUNCH OF ANY CURRENT BATTERY.
YOU COULDN'T PUT ENOUGH
BATTERIES IN A PLANE LIKE THIS
AND HAVE IT GET ANYWHERE.
A LOOK AROUND THIS DISPLAY OF
VINTAGE AIRCRAFT ILLUSTRATES THE
CHALLENGE.
IN THIS BRITISH AVIATION MUSEUM
YOU CAN TRACE THE HISTORY OF
AIRCRAFT DESIGN BACK OVER A
CENTURY.
WHATEVER THE TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES FROM ORIGINAL BIPLANES
TO SUPER SONIC, ALL OF THESE
PLANES USE ONE BASIC FUEL --
OIL.
NOW, THOUGH, THERE'S A RACE ON
TO TRY TO CHANGE THAT.
THIS IS THE BABY.
>> THIS IS THE STARTING POINT
BASICALLY.
THIS IS WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT
NOW.
>> Reporter: WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW IS THIS 19-SEATER DESIGN
THAT NEIL SAYS WILL BE IN THE
AIR IN THREE YEARS.
AN INTERIM STEP, A BIOELECTRIC
HYBRID.
JUST LIKE A HYBRID CAR, IT'S
JAMMED FULL OF BATTERIES TO RUN
ITS ELECTRIC MOTORS.
BUT IT'S ALSO GOT A LITTLE JET
ENGINE RUNNING ON PLANT BASE,
NOT FOSSIL FUEL.
TO PROVIDE EXTRA TAKEOFF POWER
AND CHARGE THE BATTERIES.
ACCORDING TO THE DESIGNER, IT'S
FUTURE PROOF.
>> IN THE FUTURE, AS WE GET TO
BETTER BATTERIES, WE SWAP OUT
THE TURBO GENERATOR, PUT THAT
POWER PACK IN, THE REST OF THE
AIRCRAFT STAYS THE SAME.
>> Reporter: OTHERS ARE TRYING
TO GO PURE ELECTRIC RIGHT NOW.
THIS NINE-SEATER GOT A LOT OF
INTEREST AT THE LAST PARIS AIR
SHOW.
>> INTERNALLY WE SAY IT'S A HUGE
BATTERY WITH SOME FLAME PAINTED
ON IT.
>> Reporter: THEY'RE HAVING TO
DESIGN A NEW MODEL NOW BECAUSE
THE BATTERIES IN THIS ONE CAUGHT
FIRE.
THE SAFEST APPROACH, THOUGH, MAY
BE THIS ONE -- HARBOR AIR IN
VANCOUVER ITSELF TAKEN THE
PISTON ENGINE OUT OF ONE OF ITS
OLD SEA PLANES AND PUT AN
ELECTRIC ONE IN.
THE THING FLIES BUT NOT VERY FAR
WHICH MAY BE OKAY FOR A SHORT
HOP SERVICE LIKE THIS.
SCALING UP IS THE PROBLEM.
THE MAJOR BUILDERS, BOEING,
AIRBUS, ARE BETTING ON IMPROVED
BIOFUEL ENGINES, BUT THEY COME
WITH THEIR OWN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROBLEMS.
THE DEVELOPERS OF THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY SAY ELECTRIC PLANES
WILL BE A COMMERCIAL REALITY
THIS DECADE.
BUT THERE'S A SAYING IN RADICAL
AVIATION DESIGN -- TAKE THEORY,
APPLY ENGINEERING, ADD MIRACLE.
FOR "CBS THIS MORNING," I'M MARK
FILLI
PHILLIPS.
>> IT DOES SEEM LIKE IT WOULD BE
A MIRACLE.
HARD TO IMAGINE THEY COULD
CREATE ENOUGH BATTERY POWER TO
GIVE YOU THE LIFT TO GET THOSE
OFF THE GROUND.
>> YES.
I'M NOT THERE YET.
I LOVE MARK'S WRITING.
HE SAYS THAT PLANE LOOKS LIKE IT